agathe a posté une story ça m'a stressé
de dingue ce n'est pas bien je suis au
bord du précipice
on devait qu'est ce qui a bien pu lui
arriver de si dramatique pour qu'elle
soit obligée d'appeler à l'aide pour
s'en sortir
je n'arrive pas à ouvrir la porte
j'avais très bien elle a un peu bloqué
il faut la tirer vers soir donc si
jamais vous attendent 10 9 en décembre
et que vous allez ouvrir des portes
chômage alors on est remonté plus loin
dans les installer c'est vrai qu'elle a
eu son bord du précipice pour des choses
qui ne semble pas si compliqué parce
qu'on fait faut appuyer sur des boutons
donc si vous êtes dans le 19e
arrondissement les blizzards et appuyer
sur des bouteilles envoyez moi un
message plein d'allant mais l'accession
des faits donc si vous êtes dans le 19e
arrondissement vous savez faire des
lacets bonjour des messages sous bout de
ma life quoi le robinet fonctionne pas
si vous êtes dans dix neuvième art
martial vous ferez des marais des
robinets pas envoyez moi un message quoi
je peux mal à y faire
rien